so that's kind of what this topic is all
about let's begin if you haven't written
these down and really do so we're
focusing today on geometric
transformations namely reflection and
translation so for each of these this is
what I start you off doing once I've got
this list down here briefly if you are
given a okay so just graph it extra plus
5x plus 6 you know we have a mental
image of what this looks like you can
see where it's two x-intercepts are how
would you reflect that let's do this the
easy way first how do you reflect that
but how would you turn that graph into
the same graph but upside down what
would you do to that okay you would
probably just take that and flapper -
I'm out the front which so we could
write instead of y equals FX if you slap
a minus sign all the way out the front
like this that's going to turn the whole
thing upside down right or a more
technical way to set your gonna reflect
it across the x-axis are you happy with
that now for reasons that are going to
become clear in a second I actually
prefer writing just in a slightly
different way I'm going to write it like
this you might say that's weird
well perfectly by the end of this lesson
I would justify why I think that's
actually a better way to write
okay that's a vertical flip it's a
vertical flip what if I wanted to flip
it from this side horizontally across
the y-axis instead of the x-axis what
would it client
I expected to get to the lesson Vimeo
now will be the time that I do it I
think the - I belongs here I can write
it here but I think it belongs here
because what effect does this have it's
a reflection in a y-value do you agree
with that like it's gets ups and downs
it gets swapped around so really that
minus sign is modifying the wire
actually doesn't mean that much Jimenez
go okay so therefore it should stand to
reason if you want to reflect not wise
but ex's again you're going to use a
minus sign but it's gonna go in a
different spot where is it gonna go it's
going to go inside the brackets with the
X cuz that's the thing is trying to muck
with right so if you graph instead of f
of X if you graph F of negative x and
you can go ahead like think about what's
going to happen when you put negative X
into here
you don't need you like this down right
now but on what's gonna happen that x
squared term what's it gonna become
still x squared that's good
what about this term what's that 5x
gonna turn it over minus 5x and that 6
just stays what is okay think VP what
are the intercepts of this guy minus 2
and minus 3 as opposed to it positive 2
and poison through you see it did
reflect exactly that woman's okay so
this is how your closet or horizontally
reflect that's fine okay now remember I
said I was gonna revisit absolute value
guy well in the same way I could ask
okay what would happen if I carry out a
reflection by instead applying an
absolute value to the whole thing what
would that look like if instead of
graphing this i graphed the absolute
these what does it look like that's not
too hard to visualize yeah all the Navy
but it's gonna flip up the case you can
draw that you're actually quite good at
that now in the same way as I thought
okay applies to the whole theme here I
started mucking around with the thing
inside so what would that look like
mmm on this familiar with that
I can't simply Chuck that in I'm not
sure what I would get if I actually did
we're next period +5 absolute value of x
plus 6 I'm not as familiar with that how
could you work now you have a you have a
meet about this you'll have some time to
work on it I in the same way I'm gonna
go even more if you know what if the
absolute value had nothing to do this
right hand side what if the absolute
value was over here I've never really
done that before
what's that gonna mean I'm not gonna ask
you to put any values on both know it
could we'll get to that later on that's
all the kinds of reflections that I'm
gonna ask you to do okay the first few
are pretty standard you can do them
without my help these ones in the middle
you can also work out with a bit more
time those are the reflections the
translations are super easy if I say
let's just go with one you know make it
not so simple
if I wanted to translate this one unit
to the right one unit to the right how's
that going to change
this is going to be X minus one isn't it
right because you can compare something
like X square and you know exactly what
that looks like we have something like X
minus 1 squared and that's just going on
so this is one unit to the right what if
I wanted to go one unit up up and down
instead of left okay now I could say
this and then add one over here ah
but but remember what I said about like
what's really being modified what's
really being modified is not the X it's
the why do you agree with that so I
think a better way even though it's
equally valid a bad way which right this
is this do you see that sure you know
how you have to tell them think
backwards with this little bit you're
like oh it's - but actually means to the
right was the same thing here it's a
minus but it actually means